hello everyone and welcome to another
exciting game from round two of the
grand HS classic here between maksimka
Sherlock Rob and Vishwanathan Anand and
I'm sure all of you noticed that both
Maxime and Anand were missing from the
2018 candidates tournament unfortunately
they didn't qualify and these are
definitely the two players that would
have made a fine contribution to the
candidates tournament but they only
accept a player so not everyone can make
it every time but I'm sure already in
the next cycle will definitely see at
least one of them so let's see this game
and I I did say I will show you some
photos as I didn't have any form across
any fun game so here we have a photo of
course and preparing to shaky fans hand
before the game here we have a nice
close-up of Yvonne and here a nice
close-up of Magnus Carlsen
this was taken already almost by the end
of game of their game and a couple of
photos from this game here we have
Maxime and Anand Anand and the movie and
the audience in the back here we have a
nice close-up of Anand he's probably
considering something and here we have
also an almost a close-up of Maxime
Bashir preparing to make a move so nice
photos as as I always will try to try to
show you some photos if I do have any
and now let's see the game and I did use
the David branch lines quote above the
board as this the theme of this game
kinda reminds me of the famous branch 10
versus Nidal game the whole Queen f3
Queen g3i idea against the Sicilian but
you'll see what I mean by this
so Maxine goes efore and and plays c5
this is Cillian and I always say this
maxime Bashir is considered to be
probably the greatest Sicilian player in
the world so playing Sicilian against
him obviously is like really challenging
him to a fight so Knight to f3 d6 now
d4c captures Knight captures and Knight
to c6 the tamaño variation
Knight to c3 winter c7 the bass track of
Bishop to e3 and now a6 we have Queen to
f3 Knight to f6 and now queenside castle
knights to e5 and now Queen the g3
painting that night as the Queen on c7
is undefended b5 expanding on the Queen
side preparing Bishop to be 783 stopping
before Bishop to b7 and here we have
this early Bishop captures on b5 and
this this seems to be like like an
improved version of branch trans idea
now you don't want to capture the bishop
definitely if you capture the bishop
then you get Knight captures you
attacking the Queen and after Queen
moves as you do have to guard that c7
square Bishop to b6 which ideas of
either night to see 790 c7 check or even
stronger if black plays properly brush
up to c7 then picking up the piece back
so after Bishop to c6 you would have to
go
Bishop to c7 attacking the Queen Queen
moves and now Queen captures on e5
grabbing back the piece and also now
defending your night as your knight on
b5 was attacked twice and after Knight
captures on e4 Knight captures on e4
Queen captures on b5 Queen captures and
Bishop captures you can give a nice
check here and after the exchange of the
bishop for night white would be up upon
but it's not all that important that
he's up upon he has to connected past
points here a and B pawn will be
extremely powerful and this Bishop is a
monster completely cutting off the black
king so this would be an idea and this
is the best black can do if he accepts
this Bishop sacrifice after Bishop
captures on b5 so of course Anand
doesn't do it rook to c8 now the
definitely and is threatening to capture
the bishop as now the rook is also
guarding the c7 square and also for the
price of one point now Anand has this
rook queen battery against the King and
c1 so Bishop to a4 and here Knight
captures on e4 by Anand also an
interesting idea definitely you have to
consider this I mean you're already
really strong here an idea like Bishop
captures on a3
of course white will not capture this
would leave the knight on c3 undefended
the question is what happens after you
simply defend Knight to e2 not this
bishop now this Knight is defended do
you move the bishop back did you really
get anything by grabbing back this pawn
you just sacrifice the pawn for activity
the question is if is bishop capture
some b2 a viable a viable option
after King captures for example black
castles and now can black use the
exposed white King to maybe bring the
rooks here to the B and C file and start
some sort of an attack probably it is
possible but since Maxime
maxime allowed this and he did prepare
for this line obviously he would be
ready would with all of the defensive
ideas so Anand plays Knight captures on
e4 now grabbing back the pawn Knight
captures and Bishop captures Bishop to
f4 now attacking the knight and here
Queen to c4 I'm pinning and preparing to
grab the bishop on a4 so Bishop captures
on e5 Queen captures on a4 and rook to
d2 here f6 kick him back the Bishop
Bishop to Bishop to d6
and now King to f7 rook to e1 Bishop to
g6 now not allowing the Queen to post
any threats here against the Jeep on and
also of course getting the bishop away
as it was attacked by the rook Bishop
captures rook captures and Queen to d6
now so this is one of the most important
ideas of maxime in this line against the
time on of black never gets to push d5
and this is completely locking blacks
pieces out of the game King to g8
preparing to bring the other look into
the game and also the King is now safe
sort of artificially castled we have f4
now and here rook F to e8 and rook F
create might not be the greatest move
the greatest move that allows black to
at least to draw the game is going to
see for Queen to c4 with some very
powerful ideas for example Queen Queen
to a2 is an idea followed by Queen a1
checkmate also now the Queen
the rook and the bishop are eyeing the
sea to pawn a lot of pressure there
so after something like Queen captures
on d7 this is this is why it's hard to
find you have to allow white to grab
your porn and also now your East six
point is attacked twice but now Bishop
to f7 is the move also very hard to find
and now after Knight captures and now
Queen to a2 threatening Queen a1
checkmate and after white stops this
then Queen a 1 check King Teddy - and
now Queen captures on b2 and this is
pretty much a force to draw knife
captures on a faith and now Queen to c3
and this is agro King to d1 and yeah you
can't go king to d1 if you go King to d1
you will lose the game after rook comes
to b8 the ideas work to be one of course
and after you stop this King see one now
you get Bishop to e2 and there is no
defense against rook to be one now you
would have to give up your queen and
then you would lose very quickly so
after Queen to c3 you have to go King to
c1 and then it's a rock we need one
checking to Quincy three check King c1
Queen e1 check and you get a three-fold
repetition drawing the game so Quincy
for definitely a very strong and
powerful idea but I mean extremely hard
to find you have to give up this pond
and play Bishop to f7 really weird but
okay rook F to e8
we have a rook to e3 Queen to see for
now but now b3 simply blocking the Queen
Queen to c7 offering a trade of Queens
and now Queen captures and rook captures
and although the material is equal on
the board and Amanda does have a bishop
it will prove to be it will prove to be
not so useful al King to be - we will
have rook to b8 now comes g4 Bishop to
f7 and now a four
rook to c5 Knight to e2 with ideas of
doubling rooks on the D file rook goes
back now comes rook to d6 with tempo
attacking the a6 pawn rogue defends it
and now rook to e3 and now you can see
that this Bishop isn't really doing all
that much it's pretty much I use a
useless piece white already double
Brooks here it's a
this is a very weak backward spawn this
was the entire idea Maxine had about
this opening that it simply creates this
terrible weakness this backwards d7
point so Bishop to ake now defending it
but this is now this Bishop is now worse
than a pawn f-5e captures on f5g
captures on f5 and now rook the c8
Knight to c3 I bring in the night now
deeper into the position worked the c5
now on and is preparing to double rooks
and the C file if it will be possible
rope to d5 now rope to c6 blocking knife
to e4 King to f7 and now rook back to d3
rook a to c7 threatening to capture the
C to pawn simply c4 g 6f captors and g
6h captors and g6 and Knight captures
and f6 this doesn't happen it was at
this point this is this is move 37 so
they didn't reach time control yet and I
believe Anand was in serious time
trouble I didn't see the live feed so if
any of you watch the game live do share
in the comments as I don't really know
what happened here g6 was played here
maxime played F captors and g6 and
Abel's in this position that I meant
resigned the game simply because it
loses upon and I mean has nothing to
show for it after pawn captures Knight
captures he's down upon and with a
terrible position this bishop is
terrible here you know very hard to play
this I mean the position is winning for
white but yeah I mean it's it's hard to
find any useful move here even if you
don't play g6 but probably on just
played it due to some serious time
trouble
so yeah they didn't even reach move 40
although yeah although I believe after
Knight captures an f6 it might be in
this position that I'm resigning the
game I'm not really sure as this is more
39 yeah I'm pretty sure it was unmoved
39 that he resigned so not even reaching
time control but yeah a very interesting
game and it kind of did remind me of
that branch 10 versus 9 or game I did I
did watch an interview with Anand after
this game and also an interview with
Maxime
I will put a link in the description
below where you can watch both an
interview with Anand and an interview
with Maxime I both of them give their
own thoughts about this game and the
white went to the way it did and I will
also put a link to the trailer from
round 2 also a very nice video for you
to check out so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it a very nice game
by Maxime and also a very nice defensive
game by Anand but I'm really not sure
what happened there probably probably
serious time trouble so yeah I would
like to thank Eric Wilkinson mark gammy
and you're a [ __ ] for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
with another interesting video thank you